discovery is a process it starts on the
page you know so you I don't read a
script and go okay I know exactly what
that character is and you know it's a
journey it's a process with the writers
and with the actors with the directors
and I still don't know if I got the
character yet but I'm working on
everything was on the page and then
bringing that into you know the season
with with Denzel you know that took on
its own life my favorite part of the
entire process is the editing process
and that's where everything comes it
comes together and you know it's it's
the final it's the final rewrite of the
movie which I which is which is always
which is great and putting the music in
and finding the right piece of music is
is all no all part of that process for
me this this was about like my two
greatest fears kind of it was like
drinking myself to death or dying in a
plane crash and I was like well I'll
just put them together and so um you
know became this this like odd Odyssey
and I was writing the movie for myself
because I didn't have a boss I was
writing it on spec really so I was able
to kind of examine you know this
character's story and I'll let the
character tell this story and I wasn't
you know when when Bob came on he was
like look trust your instinct which had
you tell this story from this
character's point of view so as much as
I would say to Bob well you know what
like these two characters like Hugh and
and and Ellen block they could argue
about and he was like no it's staying
whips point of view so that was a great
thing that you know when Bob and I
started collaborating he said stay in
that voice and just tell that story of
this guy's you know journey and swirl
and twirl yeah it's a good drama you
know they're there how r define these
days you know this speaks to you know
the screenplay being as good as it is it
was and us being on a very very tight
shooting schedule because we worked
really hard to make sure that we weren't
in you know we that we had every
precious day that we were shooting was
going to be used to make sure we got
what we needed on the screen we do that
in the in the screen writing process so
this movie that
we didn't lift a single scene in the
editing I mean we tighten them up but
every single scene that we shot is is in
the movie I don't read a whole lot of
scripts but it this was just that rare
screenplay I mean as soon as I read it I
was then I was like man this is good
this is just rich this is you know I
don't have to shoot a gun or you jump
off a building his own presence so it
was it was a real easy decision and
that's a credit John but something about
our rotten society today when it's
obviously deranged cocaine dealer gets
bring such light-hearted antics to it
how did you put that character together
with spit and glue and a lot of that
fake blow they let me take some of that
home on it I took it to after-hours
joints and made me in a couple of grand
it wasn't like we had to go to Atlanta
and make it look like LA so it was great
I mean it had that perfect look for the
further for what the film was so yeah we
tried to shoot as much in continuity as
we could and and everybody knew that we
were on a very tight schedule and
everybody came you know ready to work
you know I was it was actually the shoot
was very smooth we had you know we
didn't have many days that we lost for
weather and things like that so it's
good it's AB it's a body of work so you
know I don't say oh that's the I've done
that before I can't wait through a big
scene I can't wait yeah right and screw
it up right you've overthought it and
overworked it so I just look at the at
the whole screen I read about people's
fear of flying to a third of people have
an acute fear of flying acute fear of
flying so that means when you get on an
airplane that energy you're feeling
that's the 33.3 percent of the people on
that plane that are like I really don't
want to be on this plane you know that's
an intense energy and I'm you know I'm
one of them probably putting that energy
out there and it was funny because
Denzel said we were on a panel and
somebody said well you know what did you
think about you know if
pilot who has this issue and he said
well John did a really dramatic thing by
making him a pilot it's like this most
dramatic thing you can do he's like if
he worked at the post office it wouldn't
have been a traumatic he's like you
wouldn't get your mail it's like you
know it's like so you know it's like so
I mean you know or you get it real fast
but i really really really has to be
there overnight right you get Harling
Mays and your mail is there before you
even you know and it's open